so that
that seems like a seminal mistake by
harvard and harvard is one of the great
universities in the world
and so sort of its successes and its
mistakes are really important for the
world
uh as a beacon of like how we make
progress
so what lessons for the bigger academia
that get
that's under fire a lot these days
uh what bigger lessons do you take away
like how do we make
harvard great how do we make uh other
universities yale
mit great in the face of such mistakes
well i think that we have moved into a
model
where we the the we have the
consumerization
of education uh that is to say
we have feckless administrators
uh who make policy based on
what the students say
um now this comment is not intended to
suggest that students have
no voice in governance but it is
to suggest that the faculty are there
for a reason they are among the greatest
minds on the planet earth in their
particular fields at schools like
harvard
and yale stanford the schools that you
mentioned mit
quite literally the greatest minds on
earth they're there for
a reason things like uh curriculum and
so forth
uh are rightly in the province of
faculty and while you take input and
critique and so forth ultimately the
grown-ups in the room have to be
sufficiently responsible to take
to take charge and to uh direct
the course of a student's education and
you know you know my situation is one
example where
it really could have been an excellent
teaching moment
about the value of the sixth amendment
about what it means to treat
um what it means to treat people who
are in the crosshairs of the criminal
justice system
but rather than having that conversation
um it's just this consumerization
model uh well there's a lot of noise out
here so we're going to react in this
sort of way
higher education as well unfortunately
has been
commodified in other sorts of ways that
has
reduced or impeded hampered
these schools commitments to uh
free and robust and open dialogue
so to the degree that academic freedom
doesn't sit
squarely at the center of the academic
mission
any school is going to be in trouble and
i really hope that
that we weather
this current
political moment where um
19 year olds without degrees or running
universities
and get back to a a system
where faculty where adults
make decisions in the best interests
of the university in the best interests
of the student even to the degree though
some of those decisions may be uh
unpopular and that
is going to require a certain uh courage
um and
hopefully in time and i'm confident
that in time um administrators are going
to begin to
push back on these current trends
harvard's been around for a long time
it's been around for
a long time for a reason and one of the
reasons is that it
understands itself not to be static so i
have
every
view that
harvard is is going to adapt
and get itself back on course and be
around another
400 years at least so i mean
what this kind of boils down to is just
having difficult conversation difficult
debates
uh when you mention sort of 19 year olds
and it's funny i've seen this even at
mit
it's not that uh they shouldn't have a
voice
they should they they do seem to i guess
you have to experience it and just
observe it
they have a strangely disproportionate
power
right it's very interesting to uh to
basically
i mean you say yes there's great faculty
and so on
but you know uh it's not even just that
the faculty is smart
or wise or whatever it's that they're
just
silenced
you